our Spartan Community is reeling today
I want to start by thanking law
enforcement
including the Michigan State University
of police the Michigan State Police
the FBI
all of our local agencies First
Responders local departments
and officers as far away as Oakland
County for their efforts last night
I also want to thank the incredible
medical professionals at Sparrow who are
working hard to care for those injured
as well as all the community members
that shared tips so that
um or law enforcement like that
we mourn the loss of beautiful souls
today
and pray for those who are continuing to
fight for their lives
every Spartan student parent and staff
member should know that michiganders and
Americans everywhere are thinking of you
today
President Biden and I spoke last night
he pledged his support and the thoughts
of an entire nation
we will work together to do what is
necessary to help MSU Community heal
we're all broken by an all too familiar
feeling
another place that is supposed to be
about community and togetherness
Shattered by bullets
and bloodshed
we know this is a uniquely American
problem
today is the fifth anniversary of the
Parkland shooting
where mere weeks past the Lunar New Year
shooting at Advance Hall and a few
months passed a shooting at an
elementary school in Uvalde
and looking back at a year marked by
shootings at grocery stores parades and
so many other ordinary everyday
situations
we cannot keep living like this
our children are scared to go to school
people feel unsafe in their houses of
worship or local stores
too many of us scan rooms for exits when
we enter them
and many of us have gone through the
Grim exercise of figuring out what the
last call would be too
last night a lot of kids on this campus
made those calls
they worried for their lives and for
their friends
for their fellow Spartans
parents across Michigan were on pins and
needles
calling their kids to tell them that
they love them
as parents we tell our kids it's gonna
be okay
we say that all the time
but the truth is words are not good
enough
we must act and we will
today let's hold the MSU and East
Lansing communities close
and let's think of the families and
friends of those who have lost those
fighting for their lives
and the countless michiganders whose
lives are forever changed by yesterday's
shooting
we will get through this together
and we will do it with the full support
of the state of Michigan and the U.S
federal government and with that
thanks Governor
um I want to Echo what the governor said
about the response of law enforcement uh
those of you who might have been
listening on the scanner
you heard How Deeply complex this
operation was yesterday with young
people calling in tips constantly with a
just an unbelievable unbelievably
difficult area of environment to
navigate law enforcement did an
incredible job we had hundreds respond
from across the state
um and I just I think it's a testament
to those who hold The Thin Blue Line for
us the ones that hesitate or do not
hesitate when we need them and I think
we should recognize how desperately
needed they were last night
um in our society in general
I want to thank the doctors and nurses
and staff at Sparrow Hospital they were
on it no one wants to live through a
mass shooting like this but they were
prepared and they handled it with Grace
and Humanity
um as the representative of Oxford
Michigan I cannot believe that I am here
again doing this 15 months later
and I am filled with rage that we have
to have another press conference to talk
about our children being killed in their
schools
and I would say that you either care
about protecting kids or you don't you
either care about having an open honest
conversation about what is going on in
our society or you don't but please
don't tell me you care about the safety
of children if you're not willing to
have a conversation about keeping them
safe in a place that should be a
sanctuary
now the Spartan Community is incredibly
connected and proud we've already seen
people come together
but for me the most haunting picture of
last night was watching the cameras pan
through the crowds and seeing a young
person wearing an Oxford strong
sweatshirt
the sweatshirts that were handed out
after those kids lived through a school
shooting 15 months ago and we have
children in Michigan who are living
through their second school shooting in
under a year and a half
if this is not a wake-up call to do
something I don't know what is
in the meantime I feel confident that
our law enforcement is doing everything
that they can to understand the
situation I'm thrilled that federal law
enforcement is on scene bringing their
resources to the fight
we're not going to rest until we
understand but I think the fact that
we're having this conference so quickly
after another mass shooting in our state
should be a statement in and of itself
thanks very much
well on behalf of the the community I'm
mayor Andy Shore
uh mayor rumbick in East Lansing uh city
of Lansing this is the this is the
morning that nobody ever wants to have
this is the day that nobody ever wants
to be standing up at a lectern when you
get elected you want to talk about the
great things in your community and not
this
um but here we are I do want to thank
the the Lansing residents who who stood
up these many many tips you've heard
about came in from for many of our
residents and as a result the the
shooter was identified and
um and the threat was neutralized so
we're very proud of our citizens in
Lansing
um there's going to be so much fear it's
not just the students it's the community
I've heard from parents and citizens who
didn't know what was going on so I want
to share we have a Community Mental
Health Resource that is open 24 7. it's
a crisis services department
517-346-8200 and I also want to share in
the incredible job that was done by our
law enforcement
LPD elpd State Police Ingham County and
of course MSU this is what they train
for and today and yesterday they were
able to show that they are prepared it's
not something you ever want to do when
you train but they were prepared and and
they were excellent
as of today uh East Lansing Hannah
Center will be available to students in
need of resources and counseling will be
available all day we'll be working with
the Department of Health Services today
as well to extend other additional
things to the community I just want to
say as mayor of East Lansing I when I
introduce myself I'm the mayor of East
Lansing home at Michigan State
University we are indivisible
this Spartan will thing is real I won't
send out my deepest regrets and remorse
to the families that lost children the
fears stricken in the children at
Michigan State for my children I'm a dad
here in this community is like a
playground
but then it's where you go and have your
first experiences and taste of college
life and fun and all those types of
things and I'm I'm just shattered today
my heart aches for our community and it
will be present we'll be here in support
president Woodruff of the entire
community of Michigan State University
will stand hand in hand and this is just
the beginning we will find a way forward
I don't want to stand up here and try to
communicate that we have the answers at
this point as congressperson slot can
say we're going to find the answers and
we're going to figure some stuff out
here this is going far enough
thank you
yeah good morning everyone I'm Dr Denny
Martin I'm the interim president and uh
chief medical officers for a Hospital
Lansing
I think a lot of very dry mouths up here
this morning so bear with us and
appreciate your patience
I can confirm that last evening we cared
for five individuals who have brought
to Sparrow Hospital from East Lansing
campus the team in our level one Trauma
Center
with our emergency medicine physicians
and trauma surgeons were waiting for
them upon their arrival
I will
give a lot of thanks to the individuals
and First Responders on the scene our
ability to care for these individual
starts in the field and they did a
fantastic job
for those individuals did require a
surgical intervention to treat for their
treat their injuries one individual did
not and was taken to the critical care
unit after being triage in the emergency
department all five individuals remained
in critical condition this morning
I just I want to thank the overwhelming
uh response from our our team
um everyone in our level one Drama
Center this is you know something we
talked about this morning that we uh
that we practice for
um very often but never wants to have to
do
um and we
we did it amazingly well and um
I'm very proud of everyone
the uh
emergency department Physicians again
with our our trauma surgeons but uh
can't uh forget we had general surgeons
cardiothoracic surgeons neurosurgeons
can you get a lot of sleep last night
sorry
so many people that uh
came in
yeah there's a lot of texts that were
just uh you know I'm on my way just
within people showing up where do you
need me yeah it was it was it was sad
but uh
very proud night for all of us here so I
uh I can't speak to anything about uh
the identity of the individuals but
I'm sure we'll have some time for
questions afterwards but uh again
everyone is in critical condition at
this time but um
I've been actively being cared for by
our team that Sparrow so thank you
good morning my name is Teresa Woodruff
and I serve as the interim project
and our Spartan hearts are broken we're
grieving but as a community we're
grieving together we struggle to
comprehend
we lost families
friends classmates and our hearts go out
to the victims and families of this
senseless tragedy and we offer to each
of them the peace that passive
understatement
we continue to think for our medical
professionals at Sparrow and we know
that they are taking the best care
possible of our students
to our students
we have available to you the support
that you need at the Hannah Community
Center as was mentioned by
by mayor bacon this includes counseling
and Psychological Services as well as
Employee Assistance programs for our
faculty and staff
and we're deeply appreciative to the
governor for reaching out directly to
President Biden and for the offer of
additional Mental Health Services for
our community
as a university we also thank our law
enforcement colleagues both here and in
multiple jurisdictions
who responded immediately and continued
to protect our community today and each
day
I want to thank the staff who are on
campus today
MSU is on modified operations which
means we're an essential personnel only
for today and for tomorrow
and those staff who are here to support
our 17 000 students who are on campus
and our 50 000 students
across this great University
we thank you
I also think directly our students
faculty and staff
applied with the request to shelter in
place for hours at end without knowing
exactly what has happened
we thank you for your courage to
maintain that shelter which allowed our
law enforcement to take the actions that
they did
we ask each of you to honor your
feelings
and to take care of yourself and each
other
and together we will come back more
resilient than ever
the more ready to face what is needed in
the society which is the courage of all
of us to ensure that this never happens
again
good morning Marlon Lynch vice president
for Public Safety and chief of police
here at Michigan State University
you've heard
by several people in regards to the
response of First Responders last night
their work continued through the night
processing crime scenes
training additional statements
additional evidence
tireless work hours
we're not only Bound by our duty
but a large percentage of us are
invested in our community
we went to school here
we have children here
we have family
this is us this is part of us
the Partnerships are great
our processes will continue with this
we will continuously be joined by our
partners as we are here today with the
FBI the state police as well as Lansing
Police Department in East Lansing and I
hate to even go down the list because
there's so many agencies that responded
last night
continuously responding and asking how
can they help
and it was all in a timely manner
very timely with that
you will hear a recap of the incident
and as well as some updates based on the
events that have occurred overnight in
regards to our students that were
involved and also the suspect
foreign
deputy chief Chris Rosman with the
Michigan State University Police and
Public Safety
as you can tell this has been a long
night for a lot of us we have been
committed from the beginning
to being as transparent and getting as
much information out as as possible and
we're going to continue to do that
throughout the day and as this
investigation moves forward
I'm going to start with a brief recap of
the incident yesterday
this tragic
situation unfolded shortly before 8 30
pm
the first call that we received
was from Berkey Hall Berkey Hall is an
academic building on our Northern campus
that borders downtown East Lansing
initial calls reported shots fired in
that building
and there was a absolutely overwhelming
police response to that initial call
we had officers in that building within
minutes
and in that building they encountered
several students who were injured
we can confirm that two of the
deceased were in Berkey Hall
along with several of the victims
while the officers were managing that
scene at Berkey Hall
we began receiving additional reports of
another shooting at the MSU Union
building just to the west of Berkey hall
right on the corner of Abbott and Grand
River
officers redeployed to that location
where we did locate one additional
victim
we do have three total deceased and five
victims at the hospital we can confirm
that all three deceased were MSU
students
we can also confirm at this time that
all five of the injured victims at the
hospital were also MSU students
we will release the names
of those students later today
once we work through some notifications
and make sure that the family's aware
that we're going to release those names
the suspect in this case
was located at approximately 11 35 PM in
the city of Lansing
the suspect was located by units that
were assisting
in looking for that suspect after the
shootings
the suspect is deceased due to a
self-inflicted gunshot wound
and we are prepared to release the name
of the person who committed these
homicides at this time
we have previously confirmed that he was
43 years old he's a male
his name is Anthony
last name is McRae m-c-r-a-e
Anthony Dwayne McRae he's a 43 year old
male
we would like to sincerely thank our
community for their help
because of our quick release of the
photo the photograph from the campus
security cameras and the help from our
community
it was a caller's tip that led law
enforcement to that suspect in the city
of Lansing
we cannot thank the public in the
community and the person who called in
that report enough
for being observant
for following our messaging
and for being vigilant
and
contacting us immediately
we will continue to share resources for
the MSU Community through our
institutional
website and our MSU police and Public
Safety social media pages
we know that this news may be difficult
for those within our Campus Community
and Beyond
and it's important to remember that some
it's important to remember that the
grief that some individuals may be
experiencing is normal
and there are a number of ways in which
individuals can seek support including
talking with friends family and
colleagues process this and taking
advantage of many of the resources that
we have provided
we are prepared at this point to take
some questions
sure I'm going to turn it over to
special agent in charge Jim
good morning
I'm Jim thorowska the special agent in
charge of the FBI in Michigan
first of all
our hearts go out
to all the victims
families the students and the community
this happens much too often
like to thank all our partners in law
enforcement Chief once again thanks for
your your leadership uh just great
examples of leadership last night from
all the agencies that uh showed up short
notice
and showed selfless sacrifice to attempt
to identify find the subject and
eliminate the threat
last night when this occurred many
agencies arrived on scene the FBI
deployed agents analysts especially
teams to help an effort
to help the victims and to also find the
individual responsible
which occurred
thanks to law enforcement law
enforcement here in Michigan it's it's
the best I've seen in my 30 years in law
enforcement and I'm I was very proud of
our community
in law enforcement in the community at
large to come together to resolve this
issue this matter and we'll continue
working in the future hand in hand
to mitigate these threats and try to
make Michigan the safest places we can
for our families
so I think we are prepared to take some
questions now again I do have to
reiterate this is still fluid it's still
ongoing there are still crime scenes
that are being processed and we still
are in the process of putting together
the pieces to try to solve
to try to understand what happened and
why it may have happened so we're still
working through that so we will go ahead
and take some questions at this time
right there thank you there was a large
police presence
what is that the suspect's home
so I can't confirm the actual location
or address uh I we are aware that there
was a search warrant executed on a
residence that was connected to the
suspect in this case we're not prepared
to share that specific location at this
point
so at this point we have no additional
information on the actual weapon that
was used in the incident those are
things that we will continue to process
and look at today as part of our
investigation
we did recover we did recover a weapon
yes
there were two
um
two of the victims uh from Berkey Hall
are deceased one victim from the union
is deceased there are five additional
victims uh that are at Sparrow Hospital
I cannot confirm where all five of those
uh victims which building they were in
um I I believe most of them were from
Berkey Hall but I can't confirm that
gonna go right there
yes I understand the first uh you said
officers arrived shortly after 8 30
called but and the second building what
can you describe the time team will
avoid it so if they get to the MSU
because officers were already within a
distance of what's Happening yeah the
MSU Union is within very close proximity
to Berkey Hall it's within walking
distance I would describe it as uh less
than a block to the west of Berkey Hall
uh all indications at this point uh a
point to the the fact that the suspect
exited Berkey Holland walked over to the
MSU Union when those calls initially
started coming in from the union we were
able to quickly redeploy resources to
the union and the suspect actually
quickly fled that that building he was
not in the building for that long
how much of a time people
I can't get into specifics on the time
frame right now but that will be part of
the investigation that we'll look at is
the the time between those two uh
incidents
right there
so that's part of our investigation
today is to look at the the suspect his
background his history uh those are
things that are occurring with our state
and federal Partners right now who have
really taken the lead on helping us with
the identify the suspect especially
since that incident did occur off campus
but those are things that we're looking
at today and those will be integral to
the investigation in the background
deputy chief can you shed any light as
to the why why this happened what is
motive was why these children shouldn't
say
he you know we had the same question
last night and we had the same answer
this morning we have absolutely uh no
idea what the motive was at this point
we can confirm that the 43 year old
suspect had no affiliation to the
university he was not a student faculty
staff current or previous
so
that that's a an unknown right now and
that's what we're trying to understand
is is why this incident occurred I know
everybody
wants to know what the motive is uh we
don't have an answer right now and and
that's that's the honest truth was
anything found inside of his home that
might help with that
I can't comment on what was located in
the residence as part of that search
warrant but that is part of the ongoing
investigation
right there uh last week several schools
in Okemos and other schools across the
state were shut down for not to chewing
which was determined to be a hoax but
neither term represented connection to
that his support
so I won't get into that in detail
obviously we're looking at the
possibility of any connection there
doesn't what I will say is there doesn't
appear to be initially but those are the
type of things that our state and
federal partners are really going to
look at
um but initially it does not appear that
there's there's any connection
the back right there blue
um I understand that leaves me contact
with the suspect or who shot
Enclave what
that company so so I don't have any
additional information on the sequence
of events when law enforcement contacted
the suspect there was a tip called in
from a alert citizen that reported the
suspect that call was dispatched to
resources that we had deployed in the
field we had so many police officers on
campus as part of our unified command
structure we started deploying resources
off campus in order to respond to
reports just like this and the
responding officers encountered the
suspect and I can't comment more on that
actual interaction that is being
investigated by this Michigan State
Police right now
yeah does Mr McCray live in this
community first and then Professor for
the medical
personnel here can you tell us anything
more about the extent of the injuries
I'll start with that and I'll turn it
over to the doc um We're not gonna we're
still working to ascertain a place of
residence for the suspect as we have
said all along we want to make sure any
information that we share is accurate
and we are still working to determine um
Placer Hometown and residence for the
suspect yeah
there wasn't a consistent injury pattern
with the individuals that were brought
to the hospital but the initial reports
last evening that the injuries were
life-threatening was was correct but
there wasn't a consistent nature there's
a variety of
um
injuries associated with the gunshots
they came in
chief
were there good were there any other
weapons were covered
on the suspect or around the suspect
after he took his own life and weapons
and or ammunition
so again I can't comment on that
specifically that will be part of the
investigation that scene that occurred
is being investigated by the Michigan
State Police
um and I can't comment on what evidence
was recovered at that specific scene you
did say that you recovered one
one weapon we do have at least one
weapon yes used in the incident on
campus that's part of the investigation
and we'll work to determine that we'll
take one more question
okay
roughly you came out at around 11
o'clock shortly there after the first
news briefing and released the picture
suspect was encountered before midnight
so this tip came within minutes of you
guys releasing this photo or can you
clarify yeah no that that's absolutely
correct uh as soon as
during this incident when it was ongoing
and you can imagine the number of moving
pieces we had MSU police and Public
Safety investigators uh reviewing
surveillance footage and they quickly
determined that we had a picture of the
suspect and we quickly disseminated that
publicly and you are correct it was
shortly after we released it that he was
recognized by an alert citizen
um and so that the time frame was pretty
quick after we released it so we commend
the community and the citizen that
called that in and that was exactly what
we were trying to achieve by releasing
that picture was to generate immediate
tips for this person that was mobile
that we had no idea where he was at that
point
did any of the victims or anybody that
might have been in proximity say if the
suspect said anything or just came in
shooting or can you clarify at all how
it transpired so that will be part of
the investigation in terms of what the
suspect did or said
um there's there are there are numerous
witnesses that we have interviewed and
we will start to put those pieces
together and see
um but I don't have that information
right now in terms of the suffix said
anything when when he committed these
heinous crimes
school activities
we will provide the resources the
students need for the time period they
need and again we thank the federal
government for uh their response we will
be in modified operations for the next
two days and then we will move into a
period where cancer classes will be
canceled until Monday morning but campus
operations will resume
is the medical staff one other question
can you tell us what their prognosis is
for recovery
um with uh it's still up very early on
you know this is um
the injuries occurred just over 12 hours
ago so they're uh
um their conditions are evolving again
I'll say that they're all absolutely in
a critical condition
but there's there's varying degrees of
that but I think it's just too early
it's too early on in their course to
um to give any kind of you know
prognosis at this point can you break
down in the number of male and female
systems
first no not not at this time we can't
identify anyone
so appreciate everybody coming this
morning we are going to continue to
share information
um that concludes this briefing uh we
will be here today and working around
the clock uh to
provide resources and to continue this
investigation and we will continue to
provide information but thank you